lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
nos familiaricemos algebraica mente con
la transformación de lawrence y para que
podamos reconocerla en sus distintas
formas y poder desarrollar también
nuestra intuición para entender cómo se
comporta así que vamos a digamos sólo
vamos a escribir la transformación del
lawrence al menos como a mí me gusta
escribirla y recordemos que si estoy en
mi marco de referencia en donde
acuérdense que que yo me encontraba a la
deriva en el espacio entonces voy a
llamarle por ahora a ese marco de
referencia ese muy bien y en este marco
de referencia a ese cualquier evento en
el espacio-tiempo desde mi punto de
vista tendrá una coordenada x voy a
poner va a tener una coordenada x y
también va a tener una coordenada 7 que
voy a poner en naranja muy bien
una coordenada x una coordenada 7 y
mediante la transformación de laurents
vamos a ir a otro marco de referencia
verdad al marco de referencia s prima
verdad y este marco de referencia s
prima tendrá dos coordenadas también la
coordenada x prima y la coordenada
prima muy bien entonces vamos a escribir
la transformación de lawrence que nos
lleva de las coordenadas x y ct a las
coordenadas x prima 7 prima muy bien
entonces la coordenada x prima se
calcula como el producto de nuestra de
nuestra de nuestro factor de lawrence
verdad que multiplica a x menos menos
beta beta voy a poner aquí beta por 7
muy bien ahí tenemos la forma en la que
calculamos x prima y recordemos quién es
el factor del ourense este factor de
lawrence que escribimos con la letra
gamma es 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 1 -
de cuadrada sobre se cuadrada donde b es
la velocidad relativa que llevaba mi
amiga en su nave espacial verdad y
también podremos reescribir esto como 1
entre la raíz cuadrada de 1 - beta
cuadrada
beta cuadrada y recordemos que beta no
es otra cosa más que el cociente de la
velocidad relativa entre la velocidad de
la luz entonces sigamos escribiendo las
perdón las transformaciones de lorentz
verdad ahora vamos a escribir 7 prima y
esto otra vez se calcula como la con el
factor de lawrence perdón
el factor de lawrence por 7
- beta beta que multiplica a x verdad
que multiplica a x y esta es digamos
como ya lo he mencionado a mí me gusta
escribir la transforman la
transformación de lawrence de esta forma
porque al menos para mí me es fácil
recordarlo gracias a esta hermosa
simetría que posee verdad aquí tenemos x
menos beta 7 y aquí simplemente
intercambiamos el papel verdad
7 - beta xy por supuesto
ambas ambas coordenadas están digamos
rescatadas por el factor del lawrence
muy bien ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
manipularlo para poder entenderlo mejor
y ver cómo es equivalente a otras
expresiones como como la que
probablemente aparezca en tu libro de
texto por ejemplo verdad entonces aquí
simplemente recordemos que beta beta es
la velocidad relativa dividido entre la
velocidad de la luz verdad beta es la
velocidad relativa entre la velocidad de
la luz entonces por ejemplo en este caso
en este caso simplemente podríamos
cancelar las es verdad aquí está
dividiendo aquí multiplicando y entonces
qué es lo que obtenemos de este lado
obtenemos x prima igual a nuestro factor
de lawrence que multiplica a x menos la
velocidad relativa es lo que nos queda
que multiplica al t verdad y esto es lo
que obtenemos para la coordenada x prima
y esto es bastante interesante verdad
porque salvo gamma que es nuestro
nuestro factor de lawrence aquí lo que
tenemos es una transformación galileana
verdad es lo que nos dice la intuición
de la física newtoniana de esta forma
por ejemplo si nosotros tomamos la
velocidad relativa que sea mucho mucho
más pequeña que la velocidad de la luz
entonces recordamos que
en nuestro factor de lawrence ya lo
habíamos mencionado pues realmente se
parece mucho a una verdad y por eso es
que las transformaciones galileanas
sirven para las velocidades digamos que
ocupamos en nuestro día a día de verdad
sin embargo a medida que la velocidad
relativa se va apareciendo cada vez más
a la velocidad de la luz
entonces gamma crece muchísimo verdad
tiende a crecer muchísimo y tenemos un
resultado distinto entonces vamos a ver
ahora qué es lo que ocurre con la
coordenada para 7 prima y aquí lo que
podemos hacer es dividir en 13 en todos
lados verdad dividimos en 13 de ambos
lados verdad y entonces tenemos del lado
izquierdo de prima de prima será igual
otra vez a el factor de lawrence que
multiplica a bueno aquí por supuesto
aquí por supuesto podemos cancelar las
es aquí justo cancelamos las es y
tenemos
- v que es la velocidad relativa que
multiplica a equis y estamos dividiendo
en 13 dos veces verdad entonces estamos
dividiendo entre pse cuadrada muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos la expresión para
t prima y la razón por la que no sé por
la que no me gusta esta forma de
escribirlo es porque ya no se ve la
simetría y recordemos que estábamos
hablando de el espacio-tiempo verdad y
el espacio-tiempo es un único continuo
ya no estamos pensando al espacio como
como un digamos una cosa independiente
de lo que es el tiempo verdad y aquí
justamente ya no se ve la simetría pero
veamos vamos a analizar qué es lo que
pasa si la velocidad relativa es mucho
más chica si la velocidad relativa es
mucho más chica que la velocidad de la
luz bueno en este caso si la velocidad
relativa es mucho más chica que la
velocidad de la luz
tenemos que gamma prácticamente eso
verdad gama sería prácticamente 1 y
entonces está digamos lo que tenemos del
lado en este segundo sumando
prácticamente es 0 verdad prácticamente
será 0 y entonces lo que tendremos es
que te prima se parece muchísimo a te
verdad que también era parte de nuestra
transformación galileana de hecho acá
podríamos escribir también lo que ocurre
para la equis prima cuando la velocidad
relativa es mucho más chica que la
velocidad de la luz gamma nuestro factor
de lawrence prácticamente es 1 y
entonces tenemos que x prima se parece
mucho a x menos de t y cuando estamos
diciendo que la velocidad relativa sea
mucho más chica que la velocidad de la
luz pues sólo para asentar una idea
podríamos incluso pensar en la velocidad
de una bala una bala es mucho más lenta
que digamos que la luz verdad entonces
aquí podríamos ver
y es que las transformaciones galileanas
son una muy buena aproximación para
entender digamos los fenómenos que
ocurren en nuestro en nuestra vida
cotidiana verdad así que espero que esto
te dé mucho más intuición te recomiendo
que evalúes todas estas expresiones para
para digamos velocidades comunes de la
vida cotidiana y observa qué es lo que
ocurre cuando la velocidad relativa ve
comienza a aproximarse a la velocidad de
la luz por ejemplo puedes intentarlo con
0.9 veces la velocidad de la luz luego
puedes intentarlo con 0.99 veces la
velocidad de la luz y de esta forma
puedes ver cómo comienza a cambiar el
comportamiento de todo esto